if you and your partner are trying for a  baby you need to know when you're  ovulating now there's an even more  accurate way to tell with the Donald  Trump ovulation simply drop the Donald  Trump ovulation test into the sample of  fresh urine and wait for the result  populating try again sweetheart because  an ovulating your loser  your eggs are losers your womb is a fat  lazy Pig and your tubes a barren you put  some population test every day until you  get the result you're looking for  congratulations you're ovulating you  finally did something right now get on  your back and make a baby when it comes  to knowing when I'm fertile I trust the  Trump better than that don't know dough  you're not selling it right sweetheart  defy it go back to QVC or whatever  part-time receptionist job  you ain't don't walk away from me I'll  make sure you never work again  I support women's hell  [Applause]  [Music]